one of the things that makes human
beings great is our astonishing capacity
to learn we're always picking up new
things and correcting earlier errors but
there is one area where it seems so hard
to acquire new knowledge and change
emotional life it's one with very small
children between our first day and
around our eighth year that our
emotional hard drives are encoded it's
in this period that we learn whether we
can trust whether we like ourselves
whether we can be open where blame
belongs what to do when the world hurts
us how much we can tell others of what
de stresses us what degree of directness
can be tolerated and how much of our
naughtiness and excitement can be
witnessed and forgiven unfortunately for
humankind a catastrophic amount can go
wrong here despite all the improvements
in early infant care that's taken place
in the last century without any one
really meaning for this to happen it
remains pretty easy to pick up some
really unhelpful lessons in these early
years way before we really understand
what's going on we may acquire a lack of
trust an excessive fear of humiliation a
deep shame about our bodies there are
indirect patterns of communicating and
an inability either to be close to
someone or tolerate a measure of
distance from them we might assume that
these failures can simply get corrected
just like an early era when doing
quadratic equations
and yet when likely to realize
especially the older we get how
stubbornly encoded the faults in the
hard drive really are this can feel
absurd and humiliating there's an
understandably impatient view that one
should of course get over one's
childhood we're liable to get impatient
with people who are maybe close to 50
and still talking in wounded terms about
their parents now long-dead who said
something a little humiliating to them
decades ago but this impatient
brusqueness with the patterns laid down
in childhood is no good it may simply be
wisest to accept that there will at
points be a furious unhinged inner
five-year-old who's going to take charge
of us refuse to see the controls and a
ten
to cause mayhem we should know that we
can be enduringly and deeply wounded by
the past and should therefore when we
can manage it find words to warn those
we care about what living with us is
actually going to mean the great
learning of 20th century psychology
which has still been only patchily
assimilated is that those early years
are emotionally speaking simply
everything it would be so much easier if
it weren't like this but a die is cast
then that can almost never be reshaped
we are more or less the lifelong
prisoners of dynamics that may have been
set in motion half a century ago by
parents who weren't even mean just under
inner pressure it's a sobering situation
that calls for humility forgiveness
constant vigilance over one's own
conduct polite warnings to others and a
very black sense of humor
you